the trump presidency continues to spiral
out of control the Department of Justice
just appointed ex FBI Director Robert
Mueller as special prosecutor to
investigate Russian meddling in the 2016
election now my Russians a little rusty
but I believe the phrase is Oh meanwhile
Gizmodo is reporting that mar-a-lago
cybersecurity is so easy to hack it
likely has already been breached and in
a speech at NASA Trump called the moon
landing a hoax and said Neil Armstrong
is quote a coward who burns in hell all
right that's not true we made that one
up so naturally Trump replied by doing
what he does best lashing out at the
media like a cornered badger here his
visit speech at the Coast Guard and
commencement today no politician in
history and I say this with great purity
has been treated worse or more unfairly
by the way I think I can say with great
surety that there were a couple guys
maybe in the presidency who were treated
a little bit worse maybe maybe a couple
maybe even more who sounds like the kind
of word you would learn at Trump
University that's that's it's their
pass/fail system it's surety and not so
surely but remarkably easy to beat up on
Trump which is why we do it pretty much
every night so let's assume Donald
really has had it the worst comedians I
was looking roasts another politician
from history kill McCaffrey hey George
Washington's the only wood you can get
on the splint since you dig out of your
wife's
I feel like we should all just go home
Hilbert has one already coming
hey ser you might have been able to
overcome the Great Depression and Hitler
but still we're no match for a flight of
stairs yes boy how dare you not FDR does
it go uh Anthony Weiner's dick has been
seen by so many teenagers he's
nicknaming at twilight ha ha